timbi is not her real name and she
doesn't want to show her face because
she's afraid she'll get into trouble for
complaining reading this newspaper
article has made her angry because it
could explain why her newborn baby died
at least 10 babies have died in the same
hospital in 10 bisa township in
johannesburg in the past two months the
government blames drug-resistant
bacteria I think it's more than that
more than 10 babies hospital is hiding
information because if they're hiding
information from us like the to what was
happening with our babies the only only
thing that we knew our babies are sick
the cause of the infection isn't clear
doctors say it can lead to pneumonia and
meningitis some South Africans blame
hospital overcrowding understaffing and
poor hygiene health department managers
admit employing more nurses and doctors
could help prevent more deaths but they
are are the issues the problems that we
are dealing with these issues related to
resistance to antibiotics because when
we use antibiotics which one finish that
cause we use antibiotics that are not
prescribed or doctors prescribed
antibiotics for any other reason it
leads to our our our our bacteria not
being able to respond to these
antibiotics which is a big problem
Africa's most industrialized economy is
struggling to provide affordable quality
health care for the majority who are
poor in some neighborhoods private
clinics try to ease the burden if
patients can afford to pay to avoid the
long queues but there aren't enough
private clinics to substitute over
stress and ill-equipped state-run
hospitals the government wants to
introduce a national health insurance
scheme to try and close the gap between
the rich and the poor at the moment only
a privileged few you see in world-class
care a private hospital while millions
of mainly poor black South Africans have
to rely
understaffed and overcrowded public
health facilities the proposed insurance
scheme bill stone is to be debated in
Parliament if it becomes law the state
will control how much private health
facilities charge make it more
affordable for the poor tax rises will
be needed to pay for the scheme but some
economists say the country struggling
economy can't afford it the ruling
African National Congress says universal
health insurance is the solution but the
mothers who recently lost their baby say
is too late for them you know I don't
see myself para matar al Jazeera but on